Obama said if I am going to commit a
engage in a seditious conspiracy after
murdering American citizens and bombing
children other countries he said if I am
going to try and steal power and destroy
the United States uh uh government and
this country and the lives of the
American people I will have to own the
Press before I do it and the reason why
he has not been he has not gone down as
one of the worst Presidents in history
is because the Press has just kept lying
in his defense but I truly hope I hope
that within seven within eight years the
narrative has flipped on the horror that
was the Obama Administration The
Psychotic deranged and evil things that
man did let's just talk about the
killing of Abdul ran alaki let's talk
about the extra judicial assassinations
of several others let's talk about the
National Defense authorization act
indefinite detention provision in which
Obama said he had the right to take you
in secret in the middle of the night to
an offshore military vessel a naval
vessel and torture you